ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนิสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสบาย
ดีไหมครับผู้หญิงสบายดีค่ะรุ่นอีกสบายดี
นะคะสบายดีครับสบายดีเพิ่งตื่นเหอะยัง
สบายดีครับเพราะว่าเพิ่งตื่นใช่ก็เลยใช่
ยังไม่มีอะไรต้องคิดเยอะหรือยังวันนี้ไม่
ต้องทำงานก็เลยครับจะเอาใจก็ไปเลยค่ะ
โอเคอ้าวันนี้นี่วันนี้วันอะไรครับ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเสือเดือนกรกฎาคมครับปีพตอะไร
คะที่พ.ต.ต.
2556  5 เกือบจะบอกทียึดแล้วเมื่อกี้
Play คศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ครับค่ะแล้ว
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู next ตอนนี้เมือง
ที่คุณนิดอยู่เนี่ยเวลาแปดโมง 5 นาทีนตอน
เช้าครับ
ค่ะ 08:05 นแล้ว
ที่เมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่กี่โมงครับเมือง
ที่ครูหญิงอยู่เนี่ยเร็วกว่าครูนิ 1
ชั่วโมงนะคะก็
09:05 ค่ะตอนเช้าเหมือนกันเหมือนกันโอเค
เวลาเราห่างกัน 1 ชั่วโมงสาย
วันเวลาห่างกันเด็กชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะก็ตอน
นี้ก็เป็นตอนเช้าน้องผู้หญิงเนี่ยวันนี้
มีเกมมาเล่นกับครูนิคแล้วหาสูตรและคิด
ตั้งแต่เช้าเลยเปิดหดไม่อยากทำแล้วงั้น
เดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่นะครับ
ไม่ได้ค่ะ
ต้องเล่นนะคะ
ไม่ได้เล่นๆครับเกมอะไรครับเกมเนี่ยคือ
ที่ถ่ายเนี่ยนะคะเขาเรียกว่า 4 ต่อ 4
แฟมิลี่เกมน้องแต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
ประเทศที่อเมริกาก็มีแหละนี่นี้อ้ายกะใช่
ๆวันนี้เคยดูจริงๆคนนี้ก็ชอบรายการนี้นะ
ตลกอีนทรายที่ไทยเนี่ยก็แบบเมื่อก่อน
เนี่ยมีแล้วก็หายไปนะแต่ตอนเนี้ยก็มีอีก
แล้วมีองค์หนึ่งแล้วใช่ใช่
นกมีเมื่อไหร่ครับคือคุณนี้ก็เคยเห็นที่
คล้ายๆกันที่ของ
พิธีกรเป็นวิลลี่แมคอินทอช
เหมือนกับเป็นดารามา 4 คนมันก็อยู่ในบ้าน
จำชื่อไม่ได้ว่ารายการที่เนี่ยก็ 4 ต่อ 4
ไม่ไม่มีในเกมมั้ยใช่คิดว่าน่ะคล้ายๆกัน
เหมือนกับว่าเอามา 4 ทีมละ 4 คนแต่ก็เล่น
เกมอย่างจะ
เอานี้กลับมาโอเคใส่ค่ะตอนนี้กลับมาแล้ว
นะวันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงก็เลยจะมาเล่นเกมเกม
นี้ล่ะค่ะกับครูนิคโอ้โห
จะเป็นเวอร์ชั่นของคนไทยนะคะแต่ผู้หญิง
เนี่ยจะมีคำถามและก็จะมีตัวเลือก 3 ตัว
เลือกก็คือ A  B  C ครูนิคเนี่ยต้องคิด
ว่าคนไทยเนี่ยตอบอะไรมากที่สุดโอเค
ส่วนใหญ่ 4 ต่อ 4 เนี่ยเขาจะให้เราเล่น
เกมแข่งกันนะคะว่าคนเนี่ยตอบอะไรมากที่
สุด
ได้
ข้อแรกนะคะข้อแรกนะข้อแรกนี่บอกกับตอนนี้
มากๆ
เพราะว่าตอนนี้นะคะอากาศมันร้อนใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็คุยก็จะถามว่าค่าอากาศร้อนครูนี้
เนี่ยคิดว่าคนจะทำอะไรมาเป็นสิ่งแรก
วันนี้ร้อนจังเลยแล้วคนจะทำอะไร
ถ้าคนไทยนะมีไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงมีซอยกูเลยโอเค
โอเค rov ก็นี่ต้องสวัสดีก็ต้องคิดว่าคน
ตอบอะไรน่ารักที่สุดนะคะอ่ะหนึ่ง
กับน้ำ
ไปจัดร้อนอาบน้ำตะเองนะครับขอโทษ a อาบ
น้ำนะคะบีดื่มน้ำเย็นโอเคแล้วเราก็ใส่น้ำ
แข็ง
แล้วก็ซีเปิดแอร์
แล้วก็เปิดแอร์คุณได้คิดว่าคนจะทำอะไร
เป็นอย่างแรกถ้าอากาศร้อนก็เคมี 3 อย่าง
คือ a อาบน้ำดีดื่มน้ำเย็นค่ะรถซีเปิด
แอร์ทราย
คุณนิคิดว่า 4 เปิดแอร์เปิดแอร์
เก่งว่าจะพระคุณนี้ก็เป็นคนไป
โต๊ะสำหรับครูนิคแน่คนนี้คิดว่าเปิดแอร์
น่าจะมากที่สุดเพราะคนไทยแต่บางคนก็ขี้
เกียจอาบน้ำ
เพราะว่าอาบน้ำไปแล้วแล้วบอกก็คนไทยก็จะ
คิดว่า 1 วันอาบน้ำ 2 ครั้งถ้าอาบมากกว่า
นี้จะแปลกแล้วบางคนเพราะอาบน้ำแล้วแต่ง
ตัวสวยแล้วจะอาบน้ำใหม่อีกมันเสียเวลาใช่
เหรอดื่มน้ำเย็นคืนนี้คิดว่ามันคนไทยจะ
ไม่ค่อยมีน้ำเย็นอยู่ในตู้เย็นที่บ้านคน
ไทยก็จะไปซื้อหรือบางทีมันคิดว่าเปิดแอร์
ครับมัน
ใหญ่ที่สุดแล้วน้องกับการเดินไปแล้วก็
หยิบรีโมทแล้วก็เหมือนแก่เก่งว่าค่ะโอเค
อ่ะข้อที่ 2 นะค่ะข้อที่ 2 เดี๋ยวเอาอ่ะ
โอเคก็ครูนี้เนี่ยเพิ่งจะตัดผมมาใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ครับคำถามก็นี้เนี่ยก็จะเกี่ยวกับการ
จัดการก็
คือถามว่าเวลาผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไว้ผมยาวแล้ว
ก็อยู่ดีๆก็ไปตัดผมสั้นหรือว่าผู้หญิงไป
ตัดผมเนี่ยทำไมทำไมผู้หญิงตัดผมโอเคจะยาว
สั้น
กะแค่หน้าทำไม a
ร้อน
ร้อนก็เลยไปตัดผมนะคะบี
ขี้เกียจสระผม
ว่าผมยาวเนี่ยสระผมมันใช้เวลานานหรือว่า
ซีอีโออกหักก็คือเลิกกับแฟนมีแฟนแล้วก็
บ๊ายบายอกหักโอเค
คุณไม่คิดว่าเขาไหนมากที่สุดมากที่สุดใช่
มั้ย A คืออากาศร้อนค่ะ EP คือข้อดีคือ
อะไรนะครับ
ผมโทรมา 4 คืออกหัก
คุณนิคุณนิดตอบ 4 ปกหัก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็เป็นเล่นแล้วอยากได้เงิน
เพราะว่าเวลาที่คนคิดว่าทำไมผู้หญิงตัดผม
คนก็จะต่อว่าอกหักมากที่สุดให้เธอรู้ว่า
ผู้หญิงอ่ะส่วนใหญ่ผู้หญิงจะชอบไว้ผมยาว
ไหมคะเออใช่เราคนที่คิดว่าผู้หญิงไทยอ่ะ
ชอบไว้ผมยาวแล้วถ้าบอกว่าอากาศร้อนเลยตัด
ผมสั้นเนี่ยไม่ใช่เพราะมันก็สร้างอย่าง
นี้มันไม่ได้ช่วยให้เราเย็นขึ้นหรือเปล่า
ไม่ใช่กูดีกูรู้สึกว่าถ้าอากาศร้อนแล้ว
ตัดผมอ่ะผมมันก็จะอยู่ช่วงท้ายทอยนะกู
หน้าร้อนมากค่ะนอนอยู่ใช่ส่วนอีกอันนึง
ที่บอกว่าขี้เกียจเนี่ยอันนี้ไม่จริงขี้
เกียจอาบผมเนี่ยเพราะว่าเพื่อนคุณอีก
เนี่ยผมยาวประมาณกลางหลังเลยนะค่ะก็ขี้
เกียจสระผมจะไม่อยากตัดผมสั้น
แต่ก็อาจจะไม่ใช่แบบเหตุผลที่ไปตัดผมมาก
ที่สุดได้ไหมแต่ก็ต้องคิดว่าอย่างนั้นนะ
ท้อคุณนี้คิดว่าผู้หญิงไทยถ้าขี้เกียจสระ
ผมแล้วต้องออกไปข้างนอกก็จะมัดผมหรือว่า
แบบนี้
ผมม้วนผมมัดผมให้มันไม่ให้ดูไม่สกปรก
เพราะว่ามันถ้าเกิดว่าคนไม่ 3 ผมหลายวัน
นะผมมันจะมันเองใช่
โอเคว่ามาที่สุดก็คือปกค่ะเนาะอ่ะอ่ะ
หัวข้อต่อไปนะคะก็จะไปเนี่ยเขาก็ถามว่า
คนถ้าอยากรวยอยากมีเกินเยอะๆอยาก
รวยเนี่ยคนจะทำอย่างไรถ้าอยากรวยหรือคิด
ว่าคนไทยตอบอะไรมากที่สุดนะโอเค
เล่นคลิปโตครับโตนะคะบีทำงานทำงานทำงาน
ซีซื้อลอตเตอรี่
ว่าคนไทยตอบอะไรมากที่สุดเร่งคลิปโตโตคือ
เอง
บีทำงานซีซื้อลอตเตอรี่หรือซื้อหวยใช่ไหม
ไม่ใช่
จริงๆอ่ะคุณนิคคุณนิกะ
คุณนิค A4 ซื้อหวย
ไทยจริงๆ
ไม่แต่ตอนแรกคุณอีไก่ตัดสินใจนะว่าจะเอา
เองหรือ C เพราะทุกวันนี้เนี่ยก็มีคนที่
เล่นที่เหมือนจะซื้อคลิปโตเยอะแต่คิดว่า
ยังเป็นแค่เอาวัยรุ่นหรือซนที่อายุเยอะ
ถ้าคนอายุเยอะเหมือนพ่อแม่คุณนิที่ป.ป.ท.
60 ปีขึ้นไปเนี่ยเขาไม่ค่อยรู้เกี่ยวกับ
เทปโตก็เลยคิดว่าจะซื้อหวยมากกว่าประวัติ
กดไทยทุกคนรู้จักหวยนะคะหรือว่า
ล็อตเตอรี่พี่ชายแล้วมันง่ายเพราะว่าเดิน
ไปอ่ะเจอขาย 1 ใบซื้อ
ไส้นั่นแหละใส่คุณนิคเพิ่งซื้อเมื่อ
วาน
ขนาดไม่อยู่ที่ไทยยังซื้อไม่
ใช่ got ที่อเมริกาเขามีเหมือนกันแต่คึด
ตอนแรกในทูนิคไม่ได้อยากซื้อแต่ว่าเพื่อน
ที่ทำงานเขาบอกว่าเอ๊ยตอนเนี้ยคือที่
เนี่ยครับบันมีล็อตเตอรี่ชื่อว่า Mega
Million เคยเห็นเพื่อนกันค่ะเขาบอกว่า
ตอนนี้แจ็คพ็อตในรางวัลที่ 1
600 ล้านเหรียญสหรัฐ
ถ้าจำไม่ผิด 600 ล้านหรือ 660 ล้านนั่น
แหละเอาๆๆ 6 ได้ไหมเนี่ยนี่ๆนะใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่
คนนี้ก็เลยซื้อ
16 โอ้โหอะไรนะเธอคิดเลยก็เพิ่งจะไม่ได้
เลยอ่ะอันนี้อันนี้ก็เป็นเงินไทยนะคะ
โอ้โห
เยิ้มเกะรวยใช่รวยแน่นอนแต่ถ้ามันเลขมัน
พึ่งออกเมื่อคืนก็ไม่ถูกก็ไม่รวยเป็นวัน
ดี 1 อย่างว่าลอตเตอรี่ที่อเมริกาเนี่ย
เขาออกบ่อยเหมือนกับว่าออกอาทิตย์ละ 3
วัน
Who เราถ้ามันไม่มีคนได้รางวัลที่ 1
เนี่ยเงินรางวัลที่ 1 มันจะเพิ่มขึ้น
เรื่อยๆก็จะจะแอบมีคนได้ใช่
มั้ยอยากรวยทุกคนน้องซื้อลอตเตอรี่กะคน
รวยเร็วให้มันก็จะจริงๆแต่คนนี้คุณนี้ก็
คิดว่าเอ๊ะจริงๆเราซื้อเนี่ยอาทิตย์ละ 1
ครั้งน่ะก็โอเคลุ้นไปได้ไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไร
ไม่คิดมาก
หายสายตื่นเต้นสนุกๆตื่นเต้น
ข้อต่อไปนะคะข้อต่อไปเนี่ยเกี่ยวกับงาน
บ้าน
ถูภาพกระทู้บ้า
หน้าหมู่บ้านร้านซักผ้าหนาเขาถามว่าคุย
คิดว่าคนไทยตอบอะไรมากที่สุดนะคะว่างาน
บ้านอะไรที่ผู้หญิงจะให้ผู้ชายทำ
อ่ะ a  a
ศรัทธาว่าหน้าดีล้างจาน C ล้างห้องน้ำ
a
สภาพา
[เพลง]
ถ้าคุณนิคตอบว่าล้างจานร้านจานก๋วยใช่
วันนี้เก่งนะเป็นคำตอบที่ 2
ขอบคุณเด็กอ่ะคนที่กำลังลังเลกำลังตัดสิน
ใจว่าจะเอาล้างจานหรือล้างห้องน้ำ
สาธิตจริงอ่ะพี่หนึ่งคือซักผ้าค่ะเพิ่ง
หรอทำไมอ่ะก็ไม่รู้นะจะแบบเหมือนเคยได้
ยินมาแบบการซักผ้ามันง่ายที่สุดในคะคุณ x
มันแค่เอาผ้าเดี๋ยวก็ไปใส่เครื่องซักผ้า
ไงก็เลยคิดว่าเราก็พรุ่งนี้ไปคิดถึงซัก
ผ้าด้วยซักมือซ้ายมือก็เลยคิดว่ามันยาก
ใช่โอเคถ้าเกิดว่าซักผ้ากับเครื่องซักผ้า
พระโอเคง่ายที่สุดสายนั่นแหละมันง่ายที่
สุดผู้ชายน่าจะทำได้ข้อต่อไปนะคะ
คำถามก็คือ
มีที่ใดที่เขาจะบอกว่า
ห้ามเสียงดัง
ครับเอาต้องพูดเบาๆนะคะอันนี้นะครับ
เป้วัด
นะฮะดีห้องสมุดห้องสมุดก็คือที่เราไปอ่าน
หนังสือหน้าไปอ่านหนังสือห้องสมุดนะคะ
แล้วก็ซี
โรงหนัง
คนนี้คิดว่าที่ไหนที่เขาส่งเสียงดังแล้ว
ก็คนไทยจะตอบมากที่สุด
ลล์อะวัด B ห้องสมุดค่ะดีดีโรงหนัง
คุณนิคคิดว่า B  B ห้องสมุดห้องสมุดใช่
ไหมคะเออเอาใจค่าาเอาจริงๆนะอันเนี้ยคน
ไทยตอบห้องสมุดกับวัดใกล้กันว่าว่าเออ
ห่างกันแค่ 1% เองอ่ะผู้หญิงรู้สึกว่าวัด
เราก็
พูดเสียงดังได้มากกว่าห้องสมุดแล้วใช่คือ
สำหรับคุณนี้ก็คิดว่ากูว่าเตี้ยคนไทยจะ
ไม่พูดเสียงดังเวลาพระอยู่
ใช่ฮะพระสวดค้าส่วนหน้าตอนที่เหมือนกับ
เราไปวัดแล้วไปทำบุญไปบริจาคของเรารอพระ
ตอนนั้นเราพูดเสียงดังจะบอกพระมาเราก็จะ
แบบให้พามาแล้วมันเวลาเธออยู่โรงเรียน
แล้วมีคุณครูมาก็จะได้ใช้ส่วน
แต่ห้องสมุดห้องสมุดสำหรับคุณนิคิดว่า
เข้าไปแล้วเราต้องรู้ว่ามีเงียบเราจะไม่
ได้ยินคนเสียงดังเยอะๆก็ได้ยินก็จะต้องมี
คนมาบอกว่า
เรายิ่งแบบห้องสมุดที่
เที่ยวอเมริกาหรือว่าที่ยุโรปเนี้ยคือ
เงียบมาบวชเขาอีกนะประเทศนี้เงียบมากๆใช่
เกลือเขา
คนนี้ก็คิดว่าห้องสมุดที่ไทยอ่ะหลายคนไป
ห้องสมุดเพราะไม่รู้จะทำอะไรไม่ได้ไป
เพราะอยากอ่านหนังสือแค่แค่อยากไปอยู่ใน
ห้องแอร์ก็ค่ะ
ก็คูณดีกระทำตอนคุณนีกเรียนที่
มหาวิทยาลัยขึ้นได้ก็โอวันนี้เบื่อนะไม่
อยากไปไหนไม่รู้ว่าจะไปไหนไปห้องสมุดดี
กว่าแล้วก็ปิด
มันจะมีที่เพื่อนเป็นทีวีเล็กๆๆ
ใช่ไม่รู้ว่าที่อื่นมีไหมแต่ว่าเขาใช่แต่
ก็จะเป็นหนังที่เก่ามากๆ
รวมเพลงเด็กหญิงเคยได้ยินเหมือนกันนะว่า
ไปดูหนังที่ห้องสมุด
ใช่นั่นแหละ
ข้อสุดท้ายนะคะคุณเออ่ะครับค่ะคุณนี้คิด
ว่าคนไทยตอบอะไรมากที่สุดนะคะกับคำถามที่
ว่าคนจะทำอะไรถ้าเจอตุ๊กแกในห้องน้ำอาจจะ
ไปใช้ดูรูปตุ๊กแกจากโทรศัพท์แล้วกันนะ
แป๊ะคนนี้กลัวมั้ยโอเคโอเคทีก็วันนี้นะคะ
ไม่เคยมีหรอกตาเดี๋ยวพี่อยากได้นักเรียน
ดูอีก 1 รอบตุ๊กแกนะคะตุ๊กแกนะประเทศไทย
เนี่ยนะคะหัวหน้าหมดแล้วตุ๊กแกเนี่ยมันจะ
ชอบอยู่ในห้องน้ำเวลาที่เราจะไปอาบน้ำ
แล้วคิดว่าคนนี้คิดว่าคนไทยตอบอะไรมากที่
สุด a วิ่งหนีเจอตุ๊กแกพวกวิ่งหนีนะคะบี
กรีซนถ้าเจอนะคะหรือว่าสิ
ไม่ทำอะไร
ก็เจอปุ๊บแกก็อาบน้ำปกติ
a วิ่งหนี
de  Please  Read  4 ไม่ทำอะไร
อันนี้
จากประสบการณ์คุณนิดเนี่ยคุณนี้จะเลือกบี
ปรี๊ดคิด
ว่ากูนี่ก็ไม่ชอบตุ๊กแกเหมือนกันเลยไหมคะ
คือไม่ชอบใช่ไม่ชอบเจอตัวมันใหญ่อ่ะที่
คุณไม่เคยเจอแล้วมันเย้ไม่ชอบ
ถูกต้อง
มันที่เจอมันจะตกใจใช่ไหมก็ตกใจปุ๊บมันจะ
กรี๊ดก่อนนะผู้ชายอาจจะแบบว่าเห้ยมันก็
เหมือนกันแหละก็มันขอกรี๊ดแล้ว
บางทีอ่ะมันตกใจมากจนมันวิ่งไม่ได้
เออแล้วตกกลัวด้วยครับว่าถ้าวิ่งเนี่ยมัน
จะตามกระโดดมาหรือเปล่าเราก็เลยคิดไว้
ก่อนแล้วก็อยู่ตรงนั้นไว้ก่อนแล้วก็เห้ย
ยังไงค่อยๆเดินถอยออกมาฮ่าๆ
ทรายสายๆคุณนิก้าจำได้เลยตุ๊กแกเนี่ย
เพราะว่าที่ปีที่แล้วที่คนเล็กไปเกาะเต่า
เนี่ยเราไปอยู่ 1 อาทิตย์ค่ะบ้านเพื่อน
คุณนิคที่นั่นน่ะมีตุ๊กแกทุกคืนหน้าบ้าน
ใช่ที่ไทยใช่ไหมคะคุณอีกไอ้ที่ไทย
เจอตั้งแต่วันแรกเลยนะ
ครับเราไม่ชอบด้วยอ่ะเออเปล่าเอายังไงดี
เพราะต้องอยู่ 1 อาทิตย์อาเภอสไตล์เสนอ
สวัสดีฮัลโหลแก่ทุกวัน
ครับในเกมที่สนุกนะส่วนเด็กชายจังนะคะก็
จริงเวลาเราดูรายการนี้ก็สนุกเนาะก็เอามา
เล่นนะกับคู่นี้คุยก็เก่งมากนะคะเป็นคน
ไทยจริงๆนะคะตอบถูกนะคะโอเคค่ะแต่ว่า
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอนะเวลาหมด
แล้วโอเคไม่สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ